تغفر الكربون وتحتبس الكربون
المانج روفر المناطق الرطبه
والغابات وهي مخزون للكربون واكثر المناطق
ثراء همم في التنوع البيولوجي اذا تم
تدميده ذلك فان مخزون كبير من الكربون
اطلاقه في المناخ ومما سيعرق البلوغ هدفنا
همم نحن مئه دوله لنا اهداف همم
لحمايه 30% من اراضينا وبحارنا همم
[موسيقى]
مع كوستاريكا همم
المؤتمر الاطراف الرابع همم تناول بيولوجي
لان يسمح بالحفاظ على هذه النظم
الايكولوجيه ويعطيها مكانها خاصه ويسمح
للدول التي تاويها عقود سياسيه وماليه
لمساعدتها في الحفاظ عليها ولكن المشكله
الان انصاحب همم عمليه التدفقات ولكن لا
نصاحب الدول التي تختار
محافظ هذا المخزون للتنوع البيولوجي وهذه
البالوعات للكربون ولذلك اطلقنا هذا العام
مع العديد من الدول المتواجده الان
الكولومبيا كابون رواندا
وعدد من ممثلي الشعوب الاصليه الفلبين
والصين والولايات المتحده والدول
الاوروبيه مبادره
ليستلهم ما قمنا به
برنامج جدتي
لبرنامج محافظه ايجابي
كل دوله ومع المنظمات غير الحكوميه التي
يمكن طريقه
على هذه
المساحات والمواقع ومجموعه من الادوات
الماليه والقانونيه
غيرها لمصاحبه هذه النظم وقد بدانا هذا
هذه العقود الكولومبيا الفلبين
انضمت ونحن سنتواجد في ليفربول
في قمه تنظم مع رئيس كامبو الذي تحدث منذ
سهلا هذه نفس المباراه
لتعدديه الاطراف والعمل يجب ان نعمل معا
للحفاظ على الحلول في المناخ وتنوع
البيولوجي في المحيطات وهنا اود ان يكون
واضحا تماما الوضوح ان فرنسا ستكون همم
على موعد مع هذه اللقاءات وفيه همم لما
قلته ولذلك اي استخدام باطن البحار وقع
البحار وانا اتحمل هذه المسؤوليه ودفع
عنها في المحافل الدوليه وبصوره اكبر فاقد
اطلقنا هذا الصباح مجموعه رفيعه المستوى
لبناء منهاجي
التنوع البيولوجي ونسمح بحلول 20 23
مشتركه النقطه الرابعه بالطبع هي العداله
المناخيه
لقد اتخذنا همم
التزامات وهناك الثقه اليوم همم
تتبلور بين الشمال والجنوب هي تلك الشمال
او من بضعه اسابيع امام الامم المتحده
لنتفادها انقسام العالم فيما يتعلق بالحرب
ينطبق ايضا على المناخ العديد من الدول
تستمع الينا اليوم 100 مليار منذ كوبنهاجن
ولا نرى هذه الاموال تاتي
يجب ان نذهب الى المدى همم
نحن هناك 32
مليار تم التعهد بها يجب ان نصل الى مائه
مليار وان نقنع الدول الاثريه التي لم
توفي بالتزاماتها
وان تنفق هذه الاليات بصوره اسرع من خلال
اليات ثنائيه ومتعدده الاطراف لنكون على
موعد مع هذه الاموال وان تصل الى دول
الجنوب والا الثقه سوف تنهار
ولذلك 100 مليار بصوره سريعه
نحن عند 82 مليار ولكن اسرع
لنكون على الموعد الذي حددنا ومع التكييف
ان فرنسا تستثمر سته مليارات يورو كل عام
وهذه حصتنا العادله في هذا الجهد وفقا منذ
كوبنهاجن وفريز ومن بين سته من اليابان
هناك مليرين
فكل الدول الثانيه يجب ان توفي بهذه